WE'LL TRY AGAIN ANYWAY TO HAVE
IT.
LOUIS MIRANDA THE FORMER
D.N.C. COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR
AND JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE AN HONEST CONVERSATION
ON THIS.
PARTICULAR PARTICULARLY, AS WE
ARE -- PARTICULARLY, AS WE ARE
REMEMBERING GEORGE H.W. BUSH
WHO TAUGHT US WE CAN DISAGREE
ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
I WENT TO THE CAPITOL AFTER
LEAVING THE STUDIO TO SEE HIM.
I TOOK THE KIDS.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE TALK
ABOUT.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES ON THE ISSUES BUT
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THEM
RESPECTFULLY.
WHAT YOU LAID OUT BRINGS UP
LEGITNATE ISSUES.
THE QUESTION IS --
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
THAT IS WHAT I LIKE ABOUT WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN TIJUANA.
I FEEL DEEPLY FOR THE PEOPLE
OF TIJUANA.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING THROUGH
WHAT A LOT OF AMERICANS HAVE
GONE THROUGH.
BUT BECAUSE IT IS TIJUANA AND
IT IS MEXICO WE CAN'T DISMISS
THEM AS ANTI-HISPANIC.
WE HAVE TO LOOK FOR CLEARLY AT
WHAT THE CONCERNS ARE.
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU IS
SIMPLE ONE.
LOOKING AT THE CONCERNS WE
JUST PLAYED ON TAPE, THOSE ARE
REAL, DOES IT MAKE YOU A
LITTLE MORE EMPATHETIC TOWARD
OUR FELLOW AMERICANS WHO HAVE
SIMILAR FEELINGS?
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
EMPATHETIC ALL AROUND HERE AND
THAT INCLUDES PEOPLE WHO HAVE
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS.
BUT A LOT OF THE CONCERNS ARE
STOKED WITHOUT A BASIS OF
REALITY.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM THAT A LOT
OF THE IMMIGRANTS THAT ARE
PART OF THE CARAVAN ARE DECENT
PEOPLE FLEEING VIOLENCE OR
ECONOMIC SITUATIONS THAT ARE
UNTENABLE.
BUT THEY ARE VICTIMS ALL
AROUND BECAUSE THEY ARE BEING
VICTIMIZED BY THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS AND THE SMUGGLERS
THAT WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THEM.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH
THAT.
>> THERE IS AN A.P. ANALYSIS
THAT CAME OUT THAT 4,000 OF
THE PEOPLE DISAPPEARED IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS ON THE WAY.
>> Tucker: YES.
>> IN OTHER WORDS, THE FAMILY
HAS NO IDEA WHAT HAPPENED TO
THEM.
THEY EITHER GOT MURDERED OR --
>> RIGHT.
>> OR WORSE ALONG THE WAY.
SO THERE IS A LEGITIMATE
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS OF PEOPLE
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH
THAT.
I TOTALLY AGREE.
BUT I WANT TO SHINE THE LIGHT
ON THE VICTIMS WHO DON'T GET
REPRESENTATION OF ANY KIND IN
THE PRESS.
THOSE ARE THE CITIZENS WHO ARE
HAVING TO ABSORB LARGE
POPULATIONS OF -- I AGREE WITH
YOU, LARGELY DECENT PEOPLE.
I THINK MOST MIGRANTS WANT
WHAT I WANT.
A BETTER LIFE FOR THEIR
FAMILY.
I GET IT.
>> THAT IS RIGHT.
>> Tucker: I HAVE ALWAYS
THOUGHT THAT.
BUT HOLD ON.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE AS
DEEPLY WITH THE CITIZENS WHO
LIVES ARE BEING UP-ENDED BY
THE ARRIVAL OF THE IMMIGRANTS
AS THE UP GRANTS THEMSELVES --
AS THE IMMIGRANTS THEMSELVES.
IF YOU SEE THIS, CAN YOU SAY
THE AMERICAN CITIZENS SAY I
DON'T WANT IMMIGRATION.
WE HAVE HAD MORE THAN WE CAN
HANDLE.
THEY ARE NOT JUST RACISTS.
THEY HAVE A POINT.
>> THEY ARE NOT RACISTS BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THE OTHER SIDE THAT IMMIGRANTS
MADE OUR ECONOMY STRONGER OVER
THE YEARS.
LET ME ADD COLOR TO WHAT YOU
SAID IN THE BEGINNING.
THE POPULATION IS AGING.
WE HAVE BABY BOOMERS RETIRING.
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WE ARE
ABLE TO REPLACE IN THE ECONOMY
ARE BECAUSE OF IMMIGRATION.
WE WANT TO DO THAT IDEALLY IN
A LEGAL AND AN ORDERLY
FASHION.
>> Tucker: CAN I STOP YOU
THERE AND ASK A QUESTION.
>> NO, NO.
HOLD ON.
>> Tucker: I NEED TO ASK
THIS QUESTION.
YOU SAY OUR POPULATION IS
AGING.
WE ARE NOT REPRODUCING
OURSELVES.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
NOBODY SEEMS TO PAUSE AND ASK
WHY CAN'T YOUNG AMERICANS
AFFORD TO GET MARRIED AND HAVE
CHILDREN, AFFORD TO BUY HOMES
AND CARS AND THE SOLUTION IS
WE'LL BRING IN NEW PEOPLE.
WHAT ABOUT THE AMERICANS, THE
YOUNG PEOPLE, THE 30-YEAR-OLD
AMERICAN WHO CAN'T AFFORD TO
HAVE KIDS?
DOES ANYBODY CARE ABOUT THAT
PERSON?
MAYBE THERE IS A REAL
PROBLEM -- I NEVER HEAR THAT
PERSON ADDRESSED EVER.
>> IT'S AN INDUSTRIALIZED
COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: I'M AN AMERICAN.
HOLD ON.
I'M AN AMERICAN.
SO MY CONCERN IS FOR MY FELLOW
AMERICANS.
AND THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE
CHILDREN.
BUT RATHER THAN FIX THEIR
PROBLEMS OR EVEN THINK ABOUT
THEM WE ARE LIKE WE'LL JUST
IMPORT NEW CHILDREN.
ISN'T THAT A BACKWARD WAY
APPROACH IT?
>> WE SHOULD DO BOTH.
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS AMERICAN
COMPANIES AND STOCKS
OUTPERFORMED THE REST OF THE
WORLD BY A LOT.
THE AMERICAN ECONOMY HAS BEEN
SO STRONG IN THE LAST TEN
YEARS COMPARED TO ANYTHING
ELSE IN THE WORLD.
PART OF THE REASON FOR THAT IS
WE HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT IS
CONSTANTLY RENEWING ITSELF.
SO WE ABSOLUTELY SHOULD BE
ABLE TO HAVE AN ECONOMY WHERE
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO HAVE
CHILDREN CAN DO SO.
BUT IT DOESN'T MEAN WE
DON'T --
>> Tucker: BUT HOLD ON.
NO, NO.
YOU JUST SAID WE NEED TO BRING
IN PEOPLE BECAUSE AMERICANS
AREN'T REPRODUCING IN
SUFFICIENT NUMBERS.
MY QUESTION IS WHY AREN'T THE
LEADERS THINKING ABOUT HOW OUR
PEOPLE CAN AFFORD TO HAVE
CHILDREN?
THEY DON'T EVEN CONSIDER THAT
A SUBJECT WORTH STUDYING.
MUCH LESS TRYING TO FIX.
IT'S LIKE OH, WELL, THEY ARE
NOT HAVING ENOUGH KIDS.
WHY DON'T WE CARE ENOUGH?
>> THOSE ARE NOT MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE THINGS.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SAYING
THE LOW BIRTHRATE IS
JUSTIFICATION FOR IMMIGRATION.
I'M SAYING IT'S A TRAGEDY THAT
SAYS SOMETHING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY AND SELFISH STUPIDITY
OF THE LEADERS.
>> THE GROWTH AND THE
PROSPERITY ENABLED US TO HAVE
A STRONGER ECONOMY.
THERE IS DEFINITELY BOTH SIDES
TO THIS WHERE YOU CAN LOOK AT
WELL WORK WILL BE HURT?
IF YOU LOOK AT STATES LIKE
GEORGIA AND THE OTHERS
IMPLEMENTED ANTI-IMMIGRANT
MEASURES THAT FORCE A LOT OF
THE IMMIGRANTS OUT, WHAT YOU
SAW WAS FOOD ROTTING ON THE
VINES.
A LOT OF LOST CROPS BECAUSE
THERE WEREN'T ENOUGH PEOPLE
THERE TO WORK THEM.
SO THE REALITY IS THAT WE CAN
BOTH DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING.
AND WHO ARE AMERICAN AND WHO
HAVE LIVED THERE THEIR WHOLE
LIVES AND WANT TO HAVE
CHILDREN AND DO BETTER THAN
THEIR PARENTS.
>> Tucker: MAYBE SOMEONE
SHOULD CARE ABOUT THEM A
LITTLE BIT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING.
>> IT DOESN'T MEAN WE HAVE TO
DEMONIZE IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE
LEGITIMATE --
>> Tucker: I'M NOT
DEMONIZING ANYBODY.
I'M NOT AGAINST THE
IMMIGRANTS.
I'M FOR THE AMERICANS.
NOBODY CARES ABOUT THEM.